we've been trained since kindergarten in
our government schools to regard the
media as authoritative and as you know
hardworking people fighting for the
little guy and trying to present the
truth yet we see many many examples of
the little guy nicholas sandman is a
very obvious example uh those cadets who
are playing the circle game uh the guy
here's an easy example the guy who
photoshopped cnn into that uh gif with
trump wrestling them cnn said we reserve
the right to sue you yeah that's not to
hunt him down and destroy him for
creating a meme that's not looking out
for the little guy that's looking out
for number one
joining me is a columnist a media
personality and the author of dear
reader the unauthorized autobiography of
kim jong-il michael malus welcome to the
reuben report hello
kim jong-il and yet when you see that
online sometimes it looks like kim
jong-2 that's true the il that must be
very confusing to people uh only if
they're like you know iq of 100 or lower
i guess
i said to you right before we started i
was doing a little research and then
people see kim jong-un yeah current one
then you got un you got ill people think
it's a two you could see why there'd be
some language confusion there i think
well it's also funny when people think
him as his first name because that's the
family name and in asia they have the
last name first and some people refer to
him as like little kim it's like that's
not it yeah you could google a little
cam minute
a whole other thing comes up very
entertaining by the way you know when i
started this north korea work it was
driving me crazy that there's so many
people on tv and in other forms of media
who are running their mouths about this
country which is extremely complicated
they have no idea what they're talking
about and you know quoting atlas
shrugged i said i'm going to put a stop
to this once and for all and i kind of
did the conversation has started
shifting from you know we just need to
bomb them into oblivion to this is a
nation of what is it 25 million slaves
and our hearts should go out to them
because there are absolute victims of
this horrible regime you know i was on
an npr affiliate it was very funny uh
and she was referred to kim jong-il as a
campy figure and i said well that's a
very unfortunate choice of words and she
was rendered pretty much suicidal
because again they have concentration
camps you can see them on google earth
so whenever you see the press making
north korea out to be a carnival this is
exactly what i'm against yeah and i
that's actually one of the things that i
really want to dive into in a little bit
because i find it to be one of those
things where anything happens you know
there's a missile test that now seems to
be happening every week or whatever else
the amount of people and again you can't
pay too much attention to what's
happening on twitter but just the amount
of misinformation confusion joking about
extremely serious things when people
have no idea what the consequences are
all that there's just like it's just a
whole series yeah i was on a radio show
this week and the hosts were just
cracking jokes about north korea and i
wasn't having and he's like oh you got
to let me have my jokes i go it's like
north korean missiles you got to make
sure that they land
so
the book is humorous because
i'm like if you can make people laugh
about this situation you can get them to
understand the darkness because
otherwise it's too intense you know
there's this amazing book called nothing
to envy and you read it and you want to
jump out of window because we're so
powerless to help these people but at
the same time it's i think it's
important to understand both north korea
specifically and generally how you know
totalitarian governments work and what
that means in practice you know i was
born in the soviet union so this is
something that hits very close to home
for me you flew from new york to china
yeah and then and then a flight to
pyongyang yeah it's in the last terminal
it's one flight a day you know all the
way tucked away in the beijing airport
and even though it's illegal to go now
at that when you went how many years ago
is this 2012. okay so so not that long
ago five years ago who was going there
like when you were on the plane like
what type of people were even going it
was very international my tour group
there were a bunch of canadians there
was a guy from belgium i believe a girl
from uh
holland
um yeah that a lot of europeans like
from ireland i think this is the kind of
people who are like there's nothing else
like this on earth and let's see it you
know for what it is and as opposed to
what you're hearing in the press yeah
and when you get there
what are the security measures because
obviously they don't take too kindly to
outsiders especially people that you
know may want to talk about what's going
on well quite the opposite when you're
there you're a guest of the government
so you are treated extremely well it was
safer there than here because no one can
do anything to you because human life
means nothing and you're there as a
resource for the state so you are
treated very well uh but when you land
at least for me your whole brain is
screaming at you like you don't belong
here you know it's it's this very kind
of feeling that's almost impossible to
describe yeah so tell me about your your
time there i mean i i could go i wrote
an article for reason.com for a reason
uh about it you could look it up but
it's you know my whole principle there
was to try to break down my guide uh i
do a lot of ghost writing and when i do
that i interview the people kind of get
inside their head get past the press
releases and i'm like i'm going to use
those techniques and my guide to get her
to kind of
let me know what she knows and there was
this funny moment how they're very quick
i mean this is what people don't get the
north koreans have a sense of humor they
have their humans in jail
and
they have something there called chalema
which is a pegasus which is the symbol
of speed and i asked my guy to go if i
could send you anything from the outside
world what do you want me to send you
she goes a porsche and i go lady i'm not
sending you a porsche i'm not sending
you chilema either she goes we have the
original one here what do i need you to
send it to me so very very quick very
very funny
and she said she wanted perfume
and i go what kind of perfume and she
was struggling for the words and imagine
it's hard for us to describe perfume
scent is not something that lends itself
to language and the word she was looking
for is feminine and this is someone
who's a millionaire interesting and she
can't buy perfume because they don't
have in the whole country and i smuggled
the perfume in for her but it's when i
was telling her she had the same haircut
my mom had in like 1981 my mom has jet
black straight hair and i said you know
talking to you
makes me realize a lot of what my mom
went through back in russia and she just
stares at me she goes oh then your
mother must have hated russia and it was
this very chilling moment and someone
else yeah this is a woman who obviously
has a pretty decent job very enriched
was she a millionaire because of the job
that to even guide you so north korea
has something called uh um
which is a hierarchy based on your
loyalty to the regime so to even step
foot in pyongyang your family has to
have a good background right so to be
talking to foreigners you have to be off
the charts in terms of your family
background and one of the people you
know stayed behind on the tour he did
solo for a few days and she told him all
she wants to do is travel the world and
you know you your job is to show
tourists around and you see college kids
you know and you get to see
like my tour america canada ireland you
know belgium and you know you're never
going to be able to go ever no matter
how much money you have no matter how
much power you have in fact anyone who's
a diplomat or something like that who
leaves north korea for any reason their
family has to stay behind as hostages to
make sure you don't defect yeah i mean
that's what a crazy prophecy it's not
crazy it's brilliant i mean the level of
control this was i lay out my book this
was a methodical that this family got
this complete country under their total
control it was step by step closing the
doors putting up barriers hermetically
sealing them off from the outside world
yeah i guess i say crazy in that it's
like the crazy level of authoritarianism
you say brilliant as in not because you
like it per se but because
the the mechanism that they use to
create this power yeah is is pretty
brilliant oh yeah and it's it's so
pervasive and it's so much worse than
people think like oh they just have
these crazy ideas about the leaders it's
much worse than that it's so much worse
than people realize yeah so i want to
get to some of that obviously but for
your tour guide because this is sort of
fascinating to me so this is a
millionaire what does that even mean in
north korea if you can't get perfume
you know what does that mean to be a
millionaire what that means and this is
to me the beginning of the end of the
north korean regime it means you can
bribe your way out of trouble
so if when one of the first things i saw
when i landed the airport i was looking
at the parking lot in the back and when
the guards stopped like some rich lady
and by rich in north korea she's dressed
in like 80s closed right and she's on
her cell and he's basically like papers
please and she rolled her eyes at him
didn't even look at him showed her
whatever he needed to and he waved her
off
and as the regime has stopped being able
to provide for his citizenry the
corruption has spread throughout the
country which is a great step to
bringing down a country which is based
on glorifying the government right so
now when you're wealthy you can just pay
whoever you want to get whatever you
want and that is a you know a good step
towards getting people to in north korea
to realize this is all a house of cards
yeah what a fascinating way to look at
things it's like now the corruption and
bribery
is the good part yeah because this means
that the power
is starting to erode right they can't
control it and the best argument towards
the earnestness of their propaganda that
the kim family are divine essentially is
this cynicism and just like here
realizing what we're being presented to
as the overwhelming truth is actually a
barely poorly constructed lie i feel
like the mistakes of iraq and nobody
knows why the hell were in afghanistan
still trump is not beating wardrobes you
know there's there's stuff about there's
always this over-the-top rhetoric
related to iran but i say i don't sense
this is a guy that wants to just i think
he's actually very against
these nation buildings the bloodlust of
the establishment which i include the
corporate press cannot be overstated uh
when 2016 trump's the nominee we heard
it every single day he's crazy he's
gonna give us to world war three he's
gonna get pissed off at a tweet from
china and press the nuclear button
remember we heard this all the time
carly fiorina got asked this the second
debate the first question do you trust
president trump with his finger the
nuclear button and now uh china has
hacked our systems russia has you know
tried to interfere with their elections
and the press is constantly saying do
something about it do something about do
something do something about venezuela
so the fact that he's not
getting us into world war three is now
being used as a slide against him by the
same people who regarded that as a
problem when he was a nominee
it's horrific and this has been a long
time coming how much since the the we
talk about yellow journalism in high
school remember uh the spanish american
war and then they pretend it went away
it didn't go away the same press wants
if it bleeds it leads they can't wait to
get us into another engagement it's it's
disgraceful what happened what has to
happen with the press then and i mean
this in terms of cable news mainstream
news network news i mean this vox huff
poll sure the battle is feed all of it
the battle is won when the average
corporate journalist is regarded with
the exact same way as the average
tobacco executive they have a job
uh they're promoting their product their
product is cancerous and deadly they're
often bright people they're often good
people but be aware of what it is that
they're selling you
so how do we find some people to trust
in the mix of all this in this big mess
uh
trust trust but verify i mean i'll use
the reagan i mean trust is i'm not
interested in trusting people i'm
interested in uh trusting ideas and
creating mechanisms that people can't
enforce their wills that trust won't be
necessary like i don't need to trust
like ebay right i don't need to trust
that other guy is going to be uh
honorable because they're different
systems i can get my money refund and so
and so forth so there's no reason for me
to have a political leader trust because
systemically he's going to betray me at
some point or another
god there's a lot here malice thank you
i didn't see you until two minutes ago
you walked in here wearing this gorgeous
little thing yeah i've been known for
this look for years
is that right all of a sudden i get
phone calls who's this woman tulsi who's
been dressing like you she's so
nuts she even put a streak in her hair
to pass as me even more and i looked
this up she says she's from this state
called hawaii
i've never heard this there's a bunch of
volcanoes in the middle of the atlantic
and we're supposed to believe that this
is a state they live in volcanoes rain
of liquid metal they check the weather
and this is people this is how they
gerrymander the electoral college and
now they're trying to say graham's
estate graham i asked my friend where's
graham find me on the map he points this
little island by the booth that's sicily
you saying guam swam guam have you ever
found
they're making up words and making them
states the this is how the fake news
media gets over it anyway getting back
to her campaign i think she's great yes
i've been following her very closely and
i think it's reprehensible what's being
done to people like tulsi gabbard the
congresswoman from so-called hawaii and
all the other democratic outliers uh
this is a wonderful um change in our
politics where so many people are
realizing the nature of the enemy
something that happened to me about a
year ago a good friend of mine who i
went to i grew up with i went to college
with we both studied political science
together we've been friends for
you know our whole lives or you know 40
some odd years um he's a huge lefty now
obviously we diverge politically but we
went out for a drink and we sort of got
into it and he was getting very heated
and i just kept trying to get out of
politics i tried and i'm sure you've
been in a million of these where you
just you try to let it go and there's
something that's beyond politics and i
was trying to talk about his kids and
everything else going on
and he we couldn't get there and i
finally said to him
i said do you think
that i believe what i believe as much as
you believe what you believe great
question and without pausing with no
hesitation he said no
and i thought and then yeah and this is
a really really this is a really rare
moment for me it then it then really
escalated and i've never done this
before i swear to you i've never done
this before dave rubin i've never done
this before
i threw money down i paid for the whole
thing the whole tab right there and i
walked out i've never done anything like
that before and it's so counter to write
everything you know about me but i
thought that moment right there like you
have to sit in that now
the like i'm not attacking your motives
but you actually believe
that i can't believe what i purport to
believe what's amazing is there is a
continuum and there's lots of people who
would blurt that that out and as soon as
they heard themselves say it they'd be
like whoa whoa whoa oh okay i've gone
down the wrong path and there's but the
thing is they've been so trained uh
especially the last few years if you ask
one of these types is it possible
that trump is just crappy mediocre
william mckinley is that okay with you
and they're not going to really have an
answer because it's very important that
he is the worst president who's ever
lived although by there's very few
metrics where you can make that argument
how concerned to you that the
at the social media level and at the big
tech level that the game has been so
rigged and manipulated already that we
have no idea what's going on you know i
keep mentioning this thing about
shadow banning is now in twitter's terms
of service okay they can literally
throttle accounts we've we've known sure
that they've been doing it forever but
now they're telling us they're doing it
as of january 1st and we all just keep
playing the game as if the game is not
being rigged but the game is always
going to be rigged i mean when you have
your enemies to expect them to play fair
is extremely naive this is my soviet
mindset talking uh we did have a
president who tweeted his way into the
white house and i think what people
don't appreciate is the existential
angst it causes someone who works at a
social media company to see their
product or their program being from
their perspective subverted by those who
they despise to further their agenda
this must cause them a lot of grief but
doesn't it also cause them to you know
tighten those spigots and make sure that
as we get closer to the election that
michael malus isn't going to be hurt as
much or trump's not going to be hurt as
much or or reuben or anybody else sure i
mean the thing but we all pretend that
that's not really it like that would be
the thing that we would all be
relentlessly talking about right if
we really were trying to change
something here i i think they are losing
tools in their toolbox uh and i think i
mean you know kamala harris you know was
calling for trump to be banned from
twitter remember this yeah and she got
pushed back even from the left and when
she lost her uh campaign i did a ham
tasting on my live stream and we tried
you know different kinds of hams from
all over the world because the pig was
finally roasted so i i think they are
going to try different tactics but
because they're being called out on
their tactics instead of being called
out on the issues this is why they are
freaking out it used to be they would
say dave rubin's a racist and you would
spend months being no i'm not no i'm not
now it's dave rubin saying look at their
technique of calling me rogan everybody
else a racist as a means of preemptively
dismissing them so by you calling out
their technique it loses almost all its
efficacy you know it's funny because
like three years ago let's say when
daily beast or mother jones or any of
these awful things
these these what do you call you call
them jihadists jihadis without the
testosterone yes whenever they were
doing they would call me all these
things you know i'd fight back and then
you know i could occasionally get them
to change one line or whatever but then
they wouldn't they wouldn't actually
retweet the thing they would just change
it and nobody's seen it and whatever
it's out there it's out there for then
right stealth edit so then wikipedia can
grab from it and right and the rest of
it but it used to really upset me
obviously when i first you know like
anyone that starts getting that heat it
gets hot at first and in a weird way now
um because i have a book coming out in
april and i know
what that is going to cause that that
microscope to look at me or you know
really fine tune on me is that i'm glad
that i went through it now yeah do you
find that too that you've been through a
lot of the
the hits on this stuff and it's like
that actually makes you stronger now oh
and especially it makes my audience
stronger because they love it because
yeah because there's it's like a
greatest it's album right so it's
xenophobic racist homophobic blah blah
i'm from brooklyn i'm an immigrant yeah
i mean so when they start
when i went after george soros oh this
can you talk yeah talk about this
because this is a this was this is
exactly why i think you're such a great
thinker truly what what this whole soros
thing oh it was beautiful yeah so uh
some guy from the atlantic and i'm not
trying to be dismissive i genuinely
don't remember his name um the
atlantic's pretty terrible
they've been but
dave they've seen this is where they've
been terrible since woodrow wilson don't
i mean even before in the nation i mean
these people were the ones agitating for
world war one i mean you have to go back
so um
there was rudy giuliani made a comment
that he's more jewish than george soros
now in any other context
if you were talking to jewish people and
said someone can be culturally jewish
without actually having jewish ethnicity
as opposed to someone could have jewish
ethnicity and basically be a total [ __ ]
right this is not controversial it's
very well known and everyone everyone
knows this obama kept saying he was the
first jewish president yes this is very
known we're both jewish we know people
who are super jewish and then people who
are basically wasps and the people who
are adopted jews basically yeah who like
the culture
um and the guy from the atlantic was
like oh
in the world of trump someone can be
less jewish somebody else and he's
saying this about a literal holocaust
survivor right referring to soros yeah
but what was amazing is in the same way
it's dave rubin comma
secret klansman and homophobe comma it's
george soros comma
literal holocaust survivor now i always
say the corporate press is factual but
not truthful it is factual that george
soros survived the holocaust he was
jewish he was in hungary i believe uh he
was under nazi occupation his life was
in danger however
the
in any other context people would under
i would not even argue the experience of
jews who fled germany and got to america
is not the same as the experience of
jews who survived occupied territory is
not the same as a jew who escaped the
camps or survived the camps these are
three they're all holocaust survivors
these are these are separate things but
by using that term they're trying to say
george soros yeah multinational
billionaire is beyond criticism
specifically because of the holocaust
and they came at me blah blah blah and i
i'm like look i was born in ukraine uh
my family survived the nazis and the
kami's i went to yeshiva you're not i've
been circumcised three times you're not
gonna out-jew me that that's pretty
excessive so some guy came at me he's
like oh you know my grandfather died in
the holocaust family history doesn't
matter sometimes you could just be a
jerk and i go i paused this is one of
the few times i paused where i tweeted i
go
i was wondering who died and made you an
insufferable prick but now i guess we
know because you are not going to wave
your grandfather's ashes at me to win
some twitter beef to defend george soros
and i said the atlanta guy said if you
want to make george soros out to be some
sort of modern day anne frank i can't
stop you but this is what they do all
the time it was really funny especially
camel house a great example because they
couldn't figure out a criticism of her
was racist or sexist right so whatever
the the there's only like 10 words to
use and once you say i'm not even having
this argument with you they have no
power what is the corporate press really
like what is the psychological makeup of
the corporate press that causes this
whole thing sure so basically what you
have are the universities and that's
where the evil starts and we've been
trained since kindergarten in our
government schools to regard the media
as authoritative and as you know
hardworking people fighting for the
little guy and trying to present the
truth yet we see many many examples of
the little guy nicholas sandman is a
very obvious example those cadets who
are playing the circle game uh the
here's an easy example the guy who
photoshopped cnn into that uh gif with
trump wrestling them cnn said we reserve
the right to sue you yeah that's not to
hunt him down and destroy him for
creating a meme that's not looking out
for the little guy that's looking out
for number one i've asked a bunch of
guests this year but do you think
there's a moment where something changed
because it wasn't always this hard now i
get it's being exposed now more because
because we can all immediately tweet out
the truth the second you know they they
pump out the lie but do you think there
was some other seminal moment somewhere
along the road it was always this
horrible and this is what conservatives
don't appreciate we all learn in high
school about william randolph hurst the
spanish-american war remember the main
and yellow journalism and then they just
kind of the record scratch and now we're
into today
i have a
big thread on twitter walter durrante's
prime example he was a new york times
man covering the soviet union and while
stalin intentionally committed a
genocide via starvation of ukraine the
hall of demore he was putting out
dispatches all the time saying
there's no problem
if there is a problem it is malevolent
propaganda he said the russian people oh
there it's a little tough but they're
tightening their belts tightening their
belts is a very interesting idiom in
this context and what they what stalin
did to these people is
uh if you were a kulak which meant land
owner but pretty soon meant anyone if
you had any food in your home that was
for the people they ransacked her house
and took it and
if you weren't starving that's how they
knew you were hiding food and that's who
they targeted so they would beat people
mercilessly they would tear their house
upside down kick them out in the streets
you know to starve and
there was another reporter who and going
to this area was forbidden by the soviet
government there was a reporter who
jumped off the train
uh went to a few villages reported back
what was happening these horrors and
durante was like oh
you know he's just an anti-soviet
agitator so this has been going on for a
very long time uh they've always been
hardcore i call them jihadis without the
testosterone they have been
this is a
very demented ideal ideology that will
do everything in its power to maintain
its hold and power and only now that
they've been
fact checked in real time and called out
on their tactics in real time are people
realizing oh i'm just gonna say one more
point it's not cr i had this tweet
yesterday i said it's not about the
corruption it's about the depravity if
it was just hey i'm hiring my brother
and he's getting paid too much money
sitting his ass no one would care yeah
this is right we know they do that
that's fine we'd let that go it's like
zippity down yeah yeah
this is about amy rohrbach and jeffrey
epstein when you have a network that
knows that someone is engaged in the
sexual trade of children and their
concern is not getting an interview with
meghan markle and when this is exposed
instead of coming clean it's let's
target the person who revealed this
footage and get them fired at the
network which they went to
anyone with one flickering brain cell
would know that opening is going to have
some cost so when these politicians and
media people get up there and say well
we can't open until there's no risk
whatsoever because any risk would be too
much risk it's like that's not reality
those are nice words you've put together
and you strung them into a sentence
which is pretty impressive but but this
is not reality and then you watch you
know media matters then clips it and
then vox and huffpo and all the usual
suspects that that you talk about all
the time they all get in on it and that
is why although i don't uh directly
quote you what you refer to as the
cathedral we're watching the machine
break down right now and i think by and
large
that's a good thing
yeah one i just got handed my ass my ass
handed to me just today and i'm glad to
admit it just like you were talking
about larry elder uh you know trump had
been accused of saying that he was
speaking about white supremacists as
very fine people when in that literally
the rest of the sentence he goes i'm
specifically not speaking on white
supremacists i had thought
that believe all women was a right-wing
talking point and i tweeted this i
thought i said they said believe women
which is something we should do people
do tend to tell the truth more often
they lie and we should give people the
benefit doubt so they feel comfortable
telling their story and i tweeted this
out and molly hemingway within minutes
was like no no no the hashtag literally
was believe all women and it wasn't you
know twitter randos this is people like
carolyn maloney who's a very powerful
congresswoman from new york and some
others and i was shocked to see how
that just seems stupid because women are
human beings they're capable of lying
and now like you said on joe biden the
same people are just pivoting without a
batting an eye
i've always argued that they've always
been this bad and now i'm starting to
wonder if
they've gotten worse what are your
thoughts on that
ah see that's so interesting and that
shows how we all look at things from our
own perspective and then it's why you
need to talk to people because you have
to map your reality against theirs so
i've usually taken the counter which is
that they used to be better and that
something about the internet and the
ability for the rest of us to now expose
them has just
completely ripped their filter off on
top of the fact that you see all these
they they say they're journalists and
then you see their pieces your what
they're writing but then if you look at
everything else they're tweeting all day
long it's like it's very obvious what
your political biases are you guys don't
even hide it you know you mean you'll
have new york times in your byline and
you'll tweet some articles that lean a
little lefty or whatever but then
everything else in your feed shows
exactly what you are
um so i've always believed that it was
it had something to do with the internet
and exposing the ideas and that we can
see unedited videotapes look the the
what you just said there about the very
fine people moment joe biden literally
launched his campaign with a video that
quotes trump saying very fine people and
biden the implication is that that trump
is talking about white supremacists
which as you said is exactly the reverse
of what he said but there's a reason he
does it because he knows the media will
cover for him right so who tweets about
it then when it comes out scott adams
tried to unpack it i retweeted it you
probably did something a few of us that
go it's not even about liking trump so
much it's like it's just about
what's reality here can we but they all
do it together so biden tweets it out
and he knows no media is going to call
him on it so he can just keep doing it
and i think perhaps
and because we're holding this video for
a little bit as this biden story is just
breaking maybe by the time we release
this in uh in about a week and a half i
think it's possible that the biden one
almost feels like it could collapse the
whole system because all of the metoo
people are exposed right now they all
said believe all women and they're all
supporting biden and it's like now now
what is left what do you people have
left that's the purpose of this chapter
that that fake news is not just fake
headlines it's about manipulation
one of the things i was curious about
you know someone who had a you know you
came from the young turks and had a
leftist background you talk about this
very often
when you are front page of new york
times and you and bien shapiro are but
i'm being serious are like next to an
article that's implying that you lead to
nazism right or just even just a hatred
of any kind maybe not literal nazism
haha jewish but like white supremacy and
so on so forth you know that everyone
you've grown up with everyone went to
college with probably reads the new york
times or a large percentage of them do
on a personal level and you know some of
them are just going to do you know
they're not going to care a lot i went
to high school dave reuben they're going
to see this and they're going to no it
was a nazi yeah and like what was
happening to him he's gone from nazi is
that something that affects you like
part of me feels like you don't want to
answer this because you're giving them
what they want but is there a part of
you that's affected by this in a
personal level
well you know when i uh interview or
when you interviewed me for the book
which we'll link to below because you
asked me some of i think the most biting
pointed questions about all of this you
know there's the portion of the book
where i talk about losing a ton of my
hair because when i first got hate i was
getting hate from the people that i
thought were my friends i i you know
what i mean i just started saying hey
liberals let's be a little bit better
let's care about free speech i mean you
can see all those old videos it wasn't
like i was saying anything hateful and
yet they were saying all these horrible
things to me and people who were invited
to my wedding are now calling me a nazi
and i literally lost about 40 of my hair
and i was spraying freaking hair on you
know people can watch that why i left
the left video i am bloated and bags
under my eyes and i look freaking
terrible and i felt even worse than that
that being said and and this is
partly the purpose of the book
i am glad that i went through it
i made it to the other side and everyone
that makes it to the other side
james damore brett weinstein lindsey
shepherd ben shapiro the versions of it
that you've gone through everyone that
gets through it you're stronger after
you did it i haven't seen anyone totally
destroyed now that isn't to say people
haven't lost their jobs that isn't to
say there aren't you know people that
aren't public people who have had all
sorts of things but your choice is
either you step up against it and defend
yourself
so like when i invited what did i do
when that new york times piece came out
literally it had my the you know
youtube's leading people to the
alt-right with my giant my head was the
biggest head right there above it in the
new york times my dad has had a
subscription to the new york times for
longer than i'm alive something like 45
years he had to go to the bagel place he
goes to in long island every sunday to
have a friend walk up to him and say oh
i didn't know your son dave is a member
of the alt-right and then my dad has to
call me and say
what are we talking about here so it's
not that they don't really affect me
anymore in that i don't get stress over
it because i think i've come to know it
for what it is you know it's sort of
like well
quote you know it's sort of like a red
pill moment like it's scary at first
when you make that choice but then you
get on the other side and when you see
reality for what it is it's like these
people aren't going to destroy me
they're going to destroy themselves and
that's a little bit of what i want to
impart on people i want them to know
either you will step up and it will suck
for a while
and you know all sorts of bad stuff will
happen but your your choice is much
worse because your choice is the frog in
the boiling pot your choice is to never
live a life that is yours your choice is
to never say what you really think i
just refuse to live that way and i know
you're the same i'm live in studio with
my guest who is just outside i have not
seen him yet but i've been told that he
is wearing a tiny mask
due to proper
safety protocols related to covid
here he is michael
michael mallis
welcome to the ruby report good to see
you it's good to see you again
yes
this is very uh exciting i didn't know
what you were going to be doing today um
you told me you had something in store
for me
it's good to see you
i wish i could say the same
but i can't honestly
first off i love the suit the color is
great the shirt's nice ty the the whole
shebang where did you get this little
face get up i know you've been kopi's
very serious and you've been very
serious about it you didn't even praise
the shoes
no your shoes the whole thing is these
are sea leather
from the 70s
is that right you could when you could
get seal leather that's right yeah
that's very impressive nowadays no no no
you can't get it you have to get on the
black market now um
i have a feeling we're going to do the
entire interview this way well of course
this is we can't joke around no no this
is serious yeah yeah i don't want to
kill your grandma no thank you they're
both dead well i don't want to kill her
again already yeah yeah
uh i'm from new york as you know yeah
people you're a brooklyn guy i've lived
there all my life and now i'm at the
point where i'm joined the chorus of
well let me take a step back as a new
yorker you're always defending new york
at its worst right when people attack it
for being filthy for being crowd or for
people being rude all my life i've said
you just don't get it you don't
understand or
that's part of what makes new yorkers
tough we can survive it you can't
and only in the last year with kovid and
what mayor de blasio governor cuomo have
done
have i come around to i was wrong
and these people are right what they've
done to new york city the crown jewel of
america
you know one of the great cities of all
time is unforgivable and unacceptable
and
there's no possibility in my opinion of
things getting better
and i'm curious you think they can never
in the medium term yeah in the medium
term there's no mechanism for it to get
better if i'm a young person and i want
to make a store that sells like
artisanal socks cheeses i'm a young
restaurateur i want to open up a
cool new restaurant why would i go into
new york city now
where every single regulation is against
me where i'm being told
constantly maybe not explicitly but
implicitly we don't want you here you're
not welcome new york is not open for
business and we're just going to shut
you down at the drop of a hat
and i feel as if la
is
kind of similar in that vein that it's
going to get worse because there's no
mechanism for it to get better i'm
curious to hear your thoughts on that
yeah well as you know i think la is an
absolute disaster and i've only been to
new york once since i can't believe i'm
talking to you in this thing this is
really you look good you look this is
actually the best you've looked honestly
well of course
you have to see my hideous face
um no i've only been to new york once
since this whole thing happened i was in
midtown manhattan because i was doing
the gutfeld show at fox and it was scary
it felt like i am legend there were
there were no business people out there
are only people out walking alone with
masks and hats and it was kind of cold
so jackets and everyone looks kind of
shady and there's cops and a lot of
barricades and all that stuff and it's
like how does this ever come back and
here i mean you know the main the main i
don't want to say exactly where we are
but the main drag here still a ton of
boarded up stuff there's what what mom
and pop shop forget young people you
said young people what person that had
their business closed in the last year
that is experienced maybe even has a
little money could be like yeah let's do
it again let's do it again so newsome
can shut us down next month when we have
the climate lockdowns or covid2 or give
me something better than that the only
possibility of things getting better i
tweeted this this week if caitlyn jenner
runs on a campaign of hitting and
running governor newsom
i think she would get elected in a
landslide but here's what what people
don't appreciate
they thought one day detroit could never
go anywhere not only was detroit motor
city the home of the automobile industry
the music coming out of detroit still
resonates decades later still legendary
decades later now detroit is a bombed
out shelter of a hole in the ground of
what it used to be
hollywood in my view
is running on fumes on inertia of the
golden age you know you go to la every
pretty girl every hunk from their
hometown cup as you did comes to los
angeles to make their name to make their
mark
and now the movie industry
doesn't have that cachet it's not like
the place you have to be anymore because
thanks to the internet there's so many
more venues for young filmmakers
especially internationally to on a small
budget create and innovate something
amazing parasite you know which came out
of uh south korea yeah what won the
academy award there's such a hunger
uh for and it's not even a right or left
wing thing there's such a hunger for new
voices new creativity but hollywood and
these media establishment entities are
so corporate
that whether you're reading a comic book
or you're reading about the middle ages
or you're reading about a documentary
the messaging the culture the punch
lines are all going to be the same so
why would you come here where you could
hang up your shingle and be a filmmaker
and be
as opposed to hollywood and you're going
to have some you have an edge that way
we're going out to dinner after this are
you going to be dressed like this well
sure
how are you going to eat how you can eat
well i mean i'm on a cut i'm going to be
doing an underwear ad so
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell